what do I do now and we don't really
have the time for the algebra but a lot
of it is very consistent with what we've
already observed in their lives I'm just
going to show you like what are the bits
that make this thing work ok so this
like we saw before has an almost
identical equation to the ellipse hint
that minus like that minus sign sort of
changes everything now I want you to
have a look at some of the features that
you notice right for this particular
hyperbola which is oriented horizontally
we always start out with a horizontal
case because the exes are easier to do
it I'm how to get the intercepts do you
remember how I got the intercepts these
two year I let y equal 0 right like so
so that's why this guy vanishes now that
you think in general terms I'm not going
to get plus or minus I think I got there
what are these values in algebraic terms
they're going to come from here right
you're going to be solving x squared
equals a squared so your solutions are
plus or minus a so here's a and negative
now you got your furnace 45 up with
and then you also have your director
series so then we will write this
now just like with the ellipse you can
make some pretty phantom geometric
arguments it's the library to determine
okay well in terms of my aim maybe where
is everything now i'm not going to
rehearse that for you you can attempt it
is not difficult but what r is why I'm
excluding it is because you will feel
very very disappointed when you get here
because I to disappoint were happy
because the coordinates of the foci or
and a hyperbola are exactly the same as
the coordinates for the foci on an
ellipse that's kind of early and it's
exactly the same thing with the director
seems
it so thankfully we do not need to
remember more than craters that those
called wonders for the photo always the
corners for the phone guy and the same
for the directors it but that's not all
there is to it okay you might remember
on the ellipse there are axis of
symmetry you remember that there are
also axis of symmetry PR but you can't
really say like there's a long one in a
short one right cuz we're we're on the
exodus entry there on the coordinate
axes right so I can label in okay color
Stephanie I can't they believe this axis
here now because this is an axis that
happens when you cross from one branch I
fell open up over to the other right
when you cross over what they're doing
is they call this not the major players
they call this the transverse axis in
the transverse axis because you're
crossing that's what trains that means
for one over to the other now there's
another axis but like it doesn't have a
way through so that's why the major
minor categories that dirty make sense
okay now noting that the transverse axis
goes from times and a witch exactly like
it is in the ellipse we're eating them
put the other answers instead of minus a
to a
they're going to put it from minus B to
be okay so if i have- be here and be
here i know it's going to be smaller
I've got this line now and this is
really how there is okay most of the
time in mathematics penis names really
effectively and meaningful like
eccentricity it's a great name no one
could really come up with a great name
for this so therefore long at you
instead of collector Trenberth
transverse axis they call it the
conjugate axis now what does conjugate
me- clutching it kind of needs you know
the other one right it's like in a pair
you've got two things there's one thing
and it's conjugate right one thing is
conjugate wherever you got pairs of
anything like axes are conjugates me it
just means the other one right so
transverse has a mean you cross between
the branches conjugate just means it's
not that again
ok so what changes between these is
exactly the same as what happens what
changes on the ellipse right as a gets
bigger these are going to get further
and further at heart does that make
sense but [ __ ] I am also going to get
further apart as being against bigger it
stretches out this way so you're
changing the proportions of this thing
ok now we're going to give you a great
animation that shows you the effect of
this insect now what must quickly if you
go all the way back to the beginning and
instead of going with actual numbers you
go read on A's and B's and needs to
derive this right you go all the way
through just like you do with the herbs
with one exception you end up with this
it's a very subtle difference do you
member we did this everything from the
foci the directories issues was in terms
of A's and B's A's and E's and that's
why you've only got A's and E's here
there are no bees right and then you
look at this thing you say oh well that
must be v square it must be B squared
right but look make a really careful
note this is subtly different what's
there's some difference these guys have
swapped these guys have slots and
there's a reason why they swap why do
they have to swap why is because the
eccentricity has to be bigger than one
right you can see it right there if the
Exorcist to be a smaller than one you're
going to get a circle and ellipse or a
parabola but if it's bigger than one you
can't have one minus e squared it's
going to break down you're going to get
a square which has to be negative and we
just saw that broke down so you get a
different relationship keep the
hyperbola first of the under when you're
finding the features you Pudge this in
instead of 1 minus e square and
everything else is the same finding the
folk eyes are safe by the director suit
are the same okay now it's almost the
moment to pack up and I'm just I've
saver best last I promise for canon one
two three four difference
shapes that emerge on various values of
eccentricity crow shakes right what is
the actual thing binding beans and
thankfully hear the name is going to
come to rescue what is it ellipse
lips look at you see it there's lips in
there now we're an ellipse actually
comes from is that you take a comb and
you slice across it right in other words
you take the section a cross-section
right and this is the shape that emerges
okay you can see the ellipse you see the
Romans right there's another way
actually there are many other ways you
have a cone for example how I cut this
cone to get not an ellipse but circuit
how I kind of just straight across and
make sure it's straight across that's
the only way you'll get an exact circle
any angle and you'll get this done it's
kind of [ __ ] right circle ellipse how
would I cut this thing to get this and
the answer is I just take that shape the
same home and I go sleeper but not just
any amounts deeper a very very specific
value of steepness namely look at it
closely I try and point it towards you
so you could see have a look at the cone
have a look at the edge of the code this
thing that I've got my hand on right now
do you see the relationship between my
hands I Tendulkar's it's exactly
parallel to the slant height and that
and only that gives you the parabola if
you cut a bit too off like a bit too
steep right you're gonna rattle off
you get these guys right you see because
of the way I cut it you don't get one
piece like I've got with all of these
guys 1 2 3 they all have made it one
piece this is not made of one piece it's
made of two because you've got another
part of the code that you can to
vertically cut and that's how you get in
shape now one more thing please there
isn't here here are these beautiful
change these are the conic monic
sections they've been cut across and
that's where these shapes emerged from
right limousine so much do not say conic
sections and talking about it here
because this is where they come from
right and you can see if I muck about
with this thing right if I look about
this have a look and when I've stated
if I talk about you see I get circles of
very sighs well I would get innocence
all various signs
or maybe i would get like I'm gonna be
on the salon
aries i would get hi honey two members
from outside
I would get published sorry parabolas it
emphasizes right and lastly if I car
steep enough this way ever I'm going to
get less
you can see i guess i have bagua at
different spots like that